christian muss keine sekunde überlegen
wen sie heute welt oder besser wenn sie
nicht welt in einem tanzstudio in
lelystad am ijsselmeer gibt sie ihre
stimme ab
es ist eine art kleiner rache ich hab
ganz bestimmten dritte gewählt der sein
verschwinden christi ist eine von
tausenden müttern und vätern die in den
strudel der sogenannten kindergeld
affäre gerieten die alleinerziehende die
für die betreuung ihrer drei kinder
jahrelang staatliche zuschüsse erhielt
kommt plötzlich ins visier der
finanzbehörden
sie sei eine betrügerin und müsse das
geld zurückzahlen
so geht es vielen sozial schwachen
familien in den niederlanden darunter
viele mit ausländischen wurzeln christi
hat plötzlich 92.000 euro schulden
die behörden ignorieren ihren
widerspruch verfolgen sie erbarmungslos
ja ich wurde hütten auf der autobahn
angehalten sollte einen polizeiwagen
folgen kontrolle des finanzamtes
das auto ist beschlagnahmt sagten sie
und dann stehst du da und wie komme ich
jetzt nach hause das ist nicht unser
problem
ich konnte es lange vor den kindern
verbergen aber sie wurden älter und sie
sind nicht dumm wenn ich nachts im bett
lag hörten sie mich wein kam rüber und
fragten was ist denn mama erst in diesem
frühjahr kommt das ganze ausmaß des
skandals ans licht in lelystad und in
den haag ausgerechnet in den
niederlanden dem land das in ganz europa
für den rechtsstaat kämpft erst stürzen
die verantwortlichen minister dann die
gesamte regierung über die affäre
premierminister in all den jahren mark
rutte
seit zehn jahren koaliert er mit
verschiedensten parteien in seiner
ersten amtszeit lässt er sich vom
rechtsradikalen islamhassers geert
wilders dulden
will das treibt rückte vor sich her mit
europaskeptischen und
ausländerfeindlichen parolen der kampf
gegen vermeintliche sozialschmarotzer
wird so salonfähig
es gab in den niederlanden eine stimmung
das sozialmissbrauch hart bestraft
werden muss
das fanden nicht nur die parteien
sondern auch die wähler die harte hand
hatte breite unterstützung in unserer
gesellschaft
christian hat das zu spüren bekommen und
fasst sich ein herz in einer vorwahl
fernsehdebatte willigt sie ein dem alten
und vermutlich neuen premierminister
die stirn zu bieten sie haben mich im
stich gelassen so wie viele andere
eltern zu ihrem eigenen fach
warum denken sie dass sie als
hauptverantwortlicher dieser affäre
ihren job behalten können
der affäre was sie mitgemacht haben ist
schrecklich ihre geschichte ist
schrecklich ich verstehe die frage ist
gut ich habe sie mir auch gestellt
aber ich finde dass viele dinge doch
richtig gut gelaufen sind in den letzten
zehn jahren darauf bin ich stolz und
deshalb habe ich beschlossen
weiterzumachen
das ist meine ehrliche antwort
teflon mark strahlemann ohne
eigenschaften pragmatismus als tugend
sein fahrrad soll teurer sein als ein
gebrauchtwagen sowas mögen die sparsamen
niederländer dass er auf europäischer
bühne den geizkragen gibt auch
stabilität zählt in der krise auch wenn
rückte die korona pandemie nur mäßig
gemanagt hat lange drückt er sich um
klare ansagen wie das masken tragen
herum
die knapp bemessenen intensivbetten im
land sind schnell ausgelastet die
ansteckungszahlen fast dreimal so hoch
wie in deutschland
und rütte lässt auch das an sich
abtropfen und schiebt alles auf seinen
gesundheitsminister hugo der junge dann
immer wenn es probleme gibt es kann
musste die junge fragen weil kann er
antworten geben also dass auch da hat
man immer die idee dass die probleme bei
anderen liegen und dass er dann doch
staatsmännisch aus leiter der korona
krise in den niederlanden auftreten kann
christian hat ein schreiben vom
finanzamt bekommen
sie werde nun nicht mehr als betrügerin
geführt die schulden seien ihr erlassen
ihr vertrauen in den premierminister
kann das nicht reparieren
ich kann meinen kindern ihre jürgen
nicht zurückgeben
eine sorglose kindheit das konnte ich
ihnen nicht bieten
mark rutte lächelt den skandal einfach
weg und bildet ab morgen die nächste
regierung der niederlande